Ein forschungsteam aus den usa meldet, einen entscheidenden durchbruch beim bau
Künstlicher muskeln aus kunststoff pflanzenöl
Und elektroden künstliche muskeln herzustellen ist eine der größten herausforderungen
Beim roboterbauer denn in zukunft sollen roboter für viele anwendungen flexibel sein
Und eben aus diesem grund hauptsächlich aus weichen materialien bestehen wie funktionieren diese künstlichen muskeln was können sie wirklich und in welchen bereichen
Können sie, eingesetzt werden jetzt, ein. Klick zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Mit künstlichen muskeln könnte man nicht nur körper ähnliche prothesen
Bauen sondern sie dienen auch als grundlage für die. Sogenannten soft robots. Damit sind roboter. Gemeint die aus weichen materialien bestehen
und so zahlreiche besondere aufgaben erfüllen
könnten
beispielsweise
wäre es ihnen aufgrund ihrer flexibilität möglich bei rettungsaktionen durch geröll und schutt zu den verschütteten zu kommen
Geschmeidig wie ein. Oktopus eine entwicklung
Genau, solcher künstlicher muskeln also für soft roberts ist jetzt
Einem forschungsteam aus den usa gelungen und die wissenschafts community
bezeichnet das als echten durchbruch die hydraulisch verstärkten
selbstheilenden
elektrostatischen künstlichen muskeln bestehend aus elektroden kunststoff
Und pflanzenöl konkret aus elastischen kunststoffen die wieder in ihre ursprüngliche
Form zurückfinden auch elastomere genannt andere, wiederum aus flexiblen dünnen polymer
Plastikfolien die mit isolierenden flüssigkeiten gewillt sind wie in pflanzenöl so entsteht
ein hydraulisches
Element beschichtet mit gel das sehr dehnbar ist und elektrische ladungen leitet dazu einer der beteiligten forscher
christoph kepplinger setzt man das ganze unter spannung baut sich
Ein, elektrisches feld auf dass die verschiedenen schichten durchdringt. Und eine elektrostatische kraft auf die flüssigkeit aussieht
So wird die hülle performt. Und es entstehen bewegung die sehr unsere muskelbewegungen nl bezüglich der energieeffizienz
und der geschwindigkeit der kontraktion also hier
So zusammenziehen übertreffen sie aber sogar biologische muskeln oder sind zumindest mit ihnen auf einem level und sie können schon
Echt viel die künstlichen muskeln sind in der lage weiche gegenstände wie etwa. Rohe eier
Vorsichtig anzuheben genauso gut können sie aber auch
mehrere kilogramm in die luft stemmen oder sehr sehr schnelle
bewegungen ausführen selbst wenn elektrische durchschläge passieren also wenn irgendwas hier in kurzen wenn es den gibt es diesen vergleich zu den bisherigen
entwickelten künstlichen muskeln kein drama denn die isolierenden flüssigkeiten verteilen sich danach neu
und heilen sich selbst der nächste schritt soll sein dass dies auch auf der
Außenfläche möglich wird dass sich also auch die außen folien nach sein oder ähnlichem
selbst reparieren ein weiterer pluspunkt die herstellungsverfahren
Und benötigten materialien sind easy und preiswert herzustellen die
Erzeugung der elemente kostet nur etwa zehn cent erst ende. Letzten. Jahres hatten amerikanische kolleginnen. Und kollegen einen künstlichen muskel mit
Superkräften entwickelt nach angaben des forschungsteams des m und der harvard university könne er das 1000 fache seines eigengewichts
heben, und auch, er seit preis günstig in der herstellung nicht mehr als einen dollar sei
ihr zu kalkulieren dieser muskel ist allerdings anders aufgebaut erst besteht aus einer kammer mit einem inneren skelett aus kunststoff und
Die art und weise wie die kamera gefaltet wird entscheidet. Darüber welche bewegungen der muskel ausführt
denn, das skelett befindet sich in einer
Kammer gefüllt mit einer flüssigkeit oder luft die wird herausgeputzt so dass
Ein unterdruck entsteht so wird die bewegung hervorgerufen
So sind diese muskeln extrem leicht zunehmen aber sehr stark und vielseitig einsetzbar ein
2,6 gramm schwerer muskel könne drei kilogramm annehmen dass verglichen die wissenschaftler und wissenschaftler mit einer ente die
Ein auto stimmt durch diese erkenntnisse erhoffen, sich die forschungsteams fast. Jeden roboter für jede aufgabe
Konstruieren zu können die roboter der zukunft verstehen also nicht mehr aus blech sondern können ihre. Gestalt verändern und sind biegsam
Und er kennt es sich denken diese eigenschaften lassen sie
so vielfältige aufgaben übernehmen soft roberts können aber nicht nur pakete im lager packen sondern eben auch klar auch auf kleinsten teilen in
kugelschreiber zusammensetzen
Ihre hände sind weich und raum und das ermöglicht ihnen sowohl eine tomate ganz vorsichtig als auch eine rutschige
Plastikverpackung entsprechend zu packen ob das wieder. Ein
schritt zur
Technologischen singularität ist also dem zeitpunkt an dem die technologie den menschen überholt ja ob es diesem zeitpunkt gegeben wird und ob
Er je erreicht wird hierbei clixoom bleiben wir dran wenn er kein video dazu
Und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp ganz verpasst. Ihr kein video was passieren würde wenn
Ihr euch hier auf die abo box verlassen würde und zudem über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
Noch vor allen anderen, vom neuesten video täglich garantiert einfach hier draufklicken. Und am besten auch
Meinen schwesterkanal klicks, um, social media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
Genau, die glocke vergessen. Und hier geht es weiter mit einem weiteren video über
sensationelle entwicklungen in der robotik bis dann
bleibt dran